you are Shelby Victoria Taylor spy the
baddest [__] in the whole damn game
because you're the only woman that could
have got me married
uh we've had an overwhelming response
from fans who all have one thing on
their mind you know what it is what is
it it is Quentin Spivey a major
businessman from a major family he's a
major Playboy more importantly he's your
college buddy he's getting married
is there a question how do you feel
about it well Andy Shelby
you are terrible as you noted Quentin is
a dear friend I mean I'm happy for him
are you
I mean some people seem to think there's
more to that relationship than you're
letting on what people I mean where
would anyone get such a thing well
earlier in the season when the news
broke you seemed pretty upset let me
remind you watch
hey
he what son of one
hold on
[Music]
just enjoy the rest of the ceremony this
weekend will go without a hitch from
here forward
I am
[Music]
sorry all habits
what I meant to say is
hello Quentin
well that was an unexpected cleanse
good
maybe it cleared away some of those
demons that you've been holding on to
okay what's going on here Quentin
snap out of it this isn't you
this is me
this is just an evolved me
she has shown me the good and the bad
sides of her she
knows me and I know her she knows you
yeah
she hasn't even met you
I know you your crass insightful
sarcastic not this Deepak Chopra see you
don't know [__]
but you never asked me about who I am
and you did for what I mean you're
always hiding behind your fashion or
this attitude you never showed me
anything more spare me the revisionist
history Clinton okay the only thing you
ever wanted out of this is sex oh
because that's all you ever offered me
the rest you kept hidden behind some
wall that you think keeps everybody up
well I have to protect myself from what
there's more to it
okay so now you're a guru and a mind
reader no I just see it that's all
whatever
lay off the ayahuasca
oh and you're a wedding it will be in
the mail
Target
really
she's a global spokesperson
shall we
shall we Testament is that you
between four to New York hey Shelby
oh man you act like you don't know me
huh please don't make a scene oh you
didn't say that when you was crashing my
wedding don't worry I'm getting on the
flight thank you for the economy plus
ticket I'll enjoy that bag of pretzels
you'll never see me again [__]
everywhere everywhere I turn you're on a
goddamn billboard on the Twitter feed on
on my TV screen everywhere I look you're
like a damn ninja you're gonna just pop
up out of the blue you're everywhere
okay well not anymore enjoy living in
your wife's Shadow dress warm
can't stand you
Why'd You Come here in the first place
man why don't you just let me live my
life in peace you bring this wake of
chaos with you giving me PTSD well maybe
the monks in Tibet will shield you from
all that
what am I supposed to do without you
I'm so used to you being everywhere
you're not supposed to be you're always
there to annoy me to unnerve me to to
get up under my skin and drive me
freaking crazy
the arguing the boiling of My Blood The
Sounds I make when I'm inside okay
Jesus Christ
I can't stand it because I'm afraid that
I don't know who I'm going to be when
you're not there
frightens me
I'm not me without you I'm not
I need this even though I can't stand it
I can't stand to live without you
I've always loved you
wait not when you were with merch though
God shut up and just kiss me
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
they love to hate me
I just
I just want to be good you are Shelby
Victoria Taylor Spivey
the baddest [__] in the whole damn game
because you're the only woman that could
have gotten me to marry them
babe
just Taylor though
Shelby Spivey
well you are Fierce fine fabulous
and fully educated you play to win you
always come back with the w
go in there and remind them of who you
are and then surprise them with what
they don't know about you
okay
you got this
you're good
I beat that [__] beat that [__] that's
just how I treat that [__] choose
violence if I see that [__] okay three
six mamia
I thought you weren't gonna do that
Housewives reunion [__] oh I didn't
what's that
is that garlic okay well if a little
halitosis is the price to beat menopause
and that's just what it is with a little
mixture of Spirulina wheatgrass duck fat
and oyster sauce I haven't had a hot
flash in a week suck it menopause look
baby I think you're doing a little much
with this you ain't gonna beat menopause
ain't none of us gonna ever outrun the
clock why don't you just
age gracefully and let me love you okay
you can love me but aging gracefully
it's oxymoronic [__] okay we need to
strike while the iron is hot
and wet
why don't you meet me you beautiful man
in the bedroom in 20 minutes
shower in
dead and we can brush your teeth
okay real talk
how's my heart I mean what if this
happens again is that gonna be a hit for
me you're testing hate there's no
long-term damage to your heart you're
lucky it was a minor heart attack so in
time you can resume all normal
activities safely but in the meantime no
smoking no red meat definitely no salt
minimize alcohol and for the next few
weeks limit exercise sex Sports sorry
excuse me
um run that back
um no Sports before that exercise
Oh you mean sex
yeah I mean really none I I mean isn't
it good to like get the blood flowing I
mean you know there's reclining
positions and he could just lay there
there's God God we get it thank you
no sex but I can kiss you
well I like where this is going
on
Ah that's my favorite MO
[Music]
what are you doing
checking your pulse
okay get off of me enough of this [__]
I'm sorry
I'm nervous
I love you Quentin and I don't want you
to have another heart attack
candy bacon I can't drink whiskey can't
smoke cigars can't even connect with my
wife
maybe you're not good for my health
what did you say I mean before I got
married I had no [__] problem with my
heart I have no problem with my life I
could eat what I wanted now everything
is gonna [__] kill me kill me now man
I call it a damn day
wow oh so you want to be single again
huh fine
you go ahead
leave me for some underage rebound who
doesn't know the first thing about the
size of having a heart attack good luck
surviving that well I hope I die
[Music]
what the hell you weren't supposed to be
home already [__]
Quentin what is going on ah
um
that is
baked cauliflower that's the first time
I tried to do it I followed the recipe
perfectly I put it in for 45 minutes and
it came out burnt so I'm like okay I'll
get another one then I said well maybe
I'll make okay you're gonna burn
yourself cheese with a z
[__]
and it got burnt
let's try to do something nice for you
baby I'm can we can we just sit down and
talk for a minute
foreign
I used to be able to do everything right
I'll just do it all wrong
are you feeling okay
yeah now go ahead
earlier though I was working out and I
pinched the nerve and it felt the tingle
and I thought that I was having another
heart attack and felt so damn
embarrassed when the
EMT showed up
well baby I told you you just need to
stretch and hydrate
ones aren't they used to
use pop always say
don't get old
but
it's either that or die
and I don't want to die
I want to
make better choices you know not just
for me for for us and for our little
wayward child that we may
you know she caught me that when she
thought I was dying but
made me cry you know like a little girl
or something
maybe I don't even know who I am anymore
I want you to know I love you
shall be out
look at me [__] I love you and I'm
and I'm
I know you've been trying really hard
trying to be considerate and help me and
I made it difficult and I'm so sorry
but I really love you
difficult
I just want what's best for you because
I love you you're the only man that I've
ever loved
I care about you so much that it scares
me
you are my life Quentin Spivey
well I'm gonna be here
from now on just you and me
for us I want to be here
for our little girl
I do
and I'm gonna stop trying to reverse the
clock [__] it
[Laughter]
maybe I'll just I don't know go natural
and Stop Shaving under my arms don't
don't do that
I love you so much
[Music]